NARRATOR: Our story
opens with revolution.
After decades of cold war,
the mighty Soviet
empire is collapsing.
MAN: The wall is
effectively down.
NARRATOR: Just weeks
before the 90s begin,
the most famous symbol
of the political divide
between east and
west is toppled.
CHUNG: We as boomers lived
under the threat of nuclear war.
We lived with the Cold War.
The Berlin Wall was the
symbol of all of that.
CHUNG (over TV): Today was the
beginning of the end of
what they call
the wall of shame.
CHUNG: It was a glorious moment.
It was like a street party.
MAN (over TV): Until yesterday
the wall was a symbol of
Cold War fear and loathing.
Tonight it's the scene for
a celebration of freedom,
peace and love.
NARRATOR: As political shock
waves echo across Europe
the world watches as the
Soviet super power collapses.
MAN (over TV): The exuberance,
the delight, the passion,
they are all tangible.
40 years of Stalinist
oppression crumbling.
NARRATOR: And in December 1991,
communist leader
Mikhail Gorbachev declares
the end of the Soviet Union.
The Cold War which sparked fears
of global apocalypse is over.
CLINTON: Russia's strategic
nuclear missiles soon will
no longer be pointed at
the United States.
Nor will we
point ours at them.
(applause)
NARRATOR: As lifelong
enemies join forces,
they open up bold new frontiers.
CLINTON: Instead of
building weapons in space,
Russian scientists will
help us to build
the International Space Station.
(applause)
KURT: The space race had
been part of the Cold War,
especially in the early
days it was all about
we gotta get to the moon
before the Soviets.
MAN (over TV): They've got the
flag up, you can see the
stars and stripes.
KURT: It made sense in a
symbolic way to to show that
the old Cold War including this
ferocious space race was done.
MAN: This is an historic moment
that I'm just very excited.
Mr. Kopchev I wanna
give you a hug.
(laughter, applause)
NARRATOR: With grand designs
for a high tech future,
construction starts on a project
of cosmic scale and ambition.
BILL: The purpose of the ISS is
to be a laboratory in space.
It's the largest international
cooperative science program
that we've ever seen.
15 nations managed by five
separate space agencies,
all contributing to make
this laboratory a reality.
NARRATOR: And as mission
training begins in
Moscow and Houston,
for a launch that will
herald the new millennium,
humanity contemplates
its destiny.
BILL: One of the biggest
questions that the space station
is trying to help answer is,
is earth the only spot
in the whole universe
that we can reside or
do we have the capacity to
live and work elsewhere?